do you remember the first time that he
physically hit you yes i was sitting on
the couch and we were talking we were
having a normal conversation i think he
was using cocaine because it was like
there was a jar a jar of cocaine out on
the table i realize that sounds weird
but it's like a an actual vintage jar of
it he's drinking and we're talking and
it's there's music playing and he's
smoking cigarettes and we're sitting
next to each other on the couch and i
asked him about the tattoo he has on his
arm and i said what does it say and he
said it says wino and i laughed it was
that simple i just laughed because i
thought he was joking and
slapped me across the face he said you
think it's so funny you think it's funny
you think you're a funny
and he slapped me again i didn't say
anything i didn't react i didn't move or
freak out or defend myself right or
say what are you doing you're crazy i
just stared at him because i didn't know
what else to do and he slaps me one more
time hard